the thing I heard about Ronnie is that
he went to a party
why this is weird yeah he he attended a
neighbour's barbecue he goes I know them
do you know I know where they go he can
look at a person and tell if they are
gonna get covent is that whatever he's
saying okay goodnight can I talk one
more thing you went to two parties just
the same I'm not just one party it was a
barbecue and then the party or not
so the first party we were sitting in
the backyards way apart having a few
drinks outside was beautiful blah blah
blah and no whoa whoa whoa whoa stop the
clock the clock dude you don't know
where the [ __ ] your neighbours been you
don't know they do I see them every day
they here they don't go anywhere they're
like bounce but you don't even know if
like they perhaps when they go shopping
for food or even a food delivery if
there's some cronic like Ronnie went to
pick up a cake at the bakery for
Stephanie's birthday right am i right
you're right nobody was there though
people make a bakery were there one lady
it was one lady and nobody else in the
whole place
see he doesn't he doesn't get it doesn't
count people and then say I'm gonna get
one of these people okay all right I
don't know like why bother doing any
warranty are you talking about Ronnie
through Stephanie a birthday party last
weekend he had four guests over the
party lasted about seven hours oh my god
Ronnie insists they stayed far apart I
mean the way over dude stay wasn't even
see this is why I feel the coronavirus
can't get under control like no one
really gets what quarantine means the
backyard isn't corona free I know that
it but you're outside and it's not like
you're sitting on top of people you know
why do you feel masks No
Oh Ronnie Ronnie puppet are you partying
too we were standing a [ __ ] shot away
it's not like we were any kind of
[ __ ] danger
you